tonight everyone in this chamber is
praying for you everyone in America is
grieving for you please stand thank you
very much an incredibly moving moment
last night at the State of the Union
President Trump consoling the parents of
two teenage girls now police say that
Nisa Mickens and Kayla Cuevas were
chased down and brutally murdered by
ms-13 gang members in Long Island in New
York in 2016
three of the four people charged with
the murders are illegal immigrants
president Trump honored Nyssa and Kayla
last night by inviting their parents to
the speech we reached out to nieces
parents Elisabeth Alvarado and Robert
Mickens and both are kind enough to join
us and share their thoughts on the
evening and the reaction to that moment
to both of you I thought a lot about you
both today and the after math of the
speech and the reaction and I want to
say for my listening audience on radio
and I know all the viewers on Fox you
know no words can express how incredibly
devastated I know you must be and we
just thank you so much for being brave
enough to come on the show and talk to
us thank you so much oh you're welcome
I want to first just ask you what what
it was like to be invited to the State
of the Union speech so many politicians
haven't really confronted what ms-13 has
done to American communities Suffolk
County and Long Island especially
hard-hit in 2016 and 2017 by ms-13 what
was it like to be invited it was
definitely an honor and we were still
shocked about receiving an invite and
you know this is something that we would
if he was actually do it again we would
definitely do it yeah we would and
Elizabeth overwhelming go ahead I'm
sorry it was it was very overwhelming
and I appreciate it that you know that
he let us come there to see him it was
an honor to see him and you met with him
before the State of the Union speech
briefly and what was that like
it was good um you know when we walked
into the to his office
it was just like breathtaking and I had
nice uh spin on me so I asked him if you
would like you know if he could take it
you know for a gift and he took it and
he took pictures with it and he took
pictures with me with it and I you know
he's very genuine very nice president
have you know I really am happy that I
met him I want to ask you both what it
felt like to find out that so many
people in the room they're mostly
Democrats did not stand up when you were
recognized and when your daughter was
recognized last night well I felt it was
a very disrespectful for the simple fact
the Democratic sir was there who did not
stand up there were African Americans so
that hurts me a lot to show that they
did not have the respect or to honor
what just happened to our lives into
America's lives and it's not right you
know regardless of how they feel about
the president they should show the
respect because I was show them the
respect if that was their loved one
there was a woman on a another cable
channel earlier today and I again I
tried to put myself in your shoes
hearing some of the comments that were
made and after this amazing moment where
so many of us were literally crying with
you and her name is joy Reid and she
said this
he gives a speech tonight in which he
makes it sound like the biggest issue in
the United States are the biggest threat
is ms-13 a gang nobody that doesn't
watch Fox News has ever heard of so it
makes it sound like they are the biggest
ones you do Elizabeth like ms-13 is any
big deal I have no words I mean these
are gang members that just you know
decided to be a judge in a jury to take
my daughter out like that it's
unacceptable
I don't want to tap it to anybody else's
family but something needs to be done
and I won't stop doing what I'm doing
until everything turns out right I can
only hope and pray that or any gang
members please stop the violence it's
enough how much more but do we have this
[ __ ] before we start enforcing our
borders they should never be in this
country in the first place if they
weren't in this country in the first
place
your daughter would still be alive today
that's what's that's what makes my blood
boil they should never have been here
Robert and Elizabeth thank you I know
we're gonna check back with you and we
wish you both you know all the best in
it I know it's still searing pain for
both of you thank you so much for
spending some time with us tonight oh
you're welcome thank you for having us
like I said it's our honor god bless you
thank you